[Música]
bueno creo que todos sabemos que vivimos
en una era muy visual somos una
generación que estamos muy acostumbrada
a comunicarnos a través de las imágenes
y esto inevitablemente va a afectar
todos los aspectos de nuestras vidas así
que hoy quiero hablar con ustedes sobre
cómo esto afecta el aspecto de nuestra
identidad cultural en honduras
cuando hablamos de estética cuando
hablamos de estética hablamos de todo lo
que es visual así que cuando decimos
estética cultural nos referimos a la
visualización que nos hacemos cuando
hablamos de honduras cómo se ve el ser
hondureño y el vivir acá
muy posiblemente las primeras imágenes
que se nos vienen a la mente cuando
hablamos de estética cultural son estas
nuestros símbolos patrios como la
bandera la brasa bola el escudo de la
guacamaya etcétera pero eso no son las
imágenes de las que quiero hablar hoy
sino que quiero hablar sobre las
imágenes que en los últimos años se han
hecho muy populares gracias a las redes
sociales imágenes como éstas bueno estas
son imágenes que muestran muchas veces
nuestros tesoros y nuestras costumbres
en honduras aquí tenemos por ejemplo el
fuerte de trujillo por la panzada que
las ruinas de copán aquí tenemos un par
de otro ejemplo tenemos unas personas
haciendo rafting la catedral de
comayagua y unos delfines en la isla de
roatán todas esas imágenes
buscan mostrar a honduras de una manera
positiva y nosotros la vemos en
fotografía sino que también muchas veces
las vemos en vídeos aquí tenemos un
vídeo de manu martínez
vemos que hay personas vestidas de traje
típico bailando en las ruinas y abajo
vestida con vestimenta maya verdad la
conversación que quiero tener con
ustedes entonces es precisamente sobre
la falta de cotidianidad que existe en
las imágenes que nos representan y
después vamos a hablar un poco sobre el
arte y cómo lo podemos usar para
incorporar nuestras vidas diarias en
nuestra estética cultural
ok entonces qué papel juega el arte en
todo eso si nos preguntamos por qué es
importante el arte bueno esa podría ser
una conversación larga por sí sola pero
hoy les quiero hablar de un concepto que
descubrí hace un par de años que hizo
que cambiarán mucho las imágenes que se
me venían a la mente cuando yo pensaba
en honduras verdad y también fue un
concepto que la verdad cambió mi manera
de ver la vida en general
el concepto es de un ensayo que se llame
el arte como artificio de un escritor
ruso llamado víctor shklovski que fue
escrito en el año 1917 y les tengo dos
citas de sense yo que les quiero
compartir la primera dice si las
complejas vidas de tantas personas se
viven inconscientemente es como si estas
vidas nunca hubiesen existido ok de que
nos está hablando aquí pues nos está
hablando de una trampa en la que muchas
veces caemos que es la de pensar que el
ordinario es aburrido verdad si estamos
acostumbrados a que todos los días nos
lavamos los dientes hacemos compras en
la pulpería desempolvamos los muebles
etcétera llega un momento en que
empezamos a hacer todas esas cosas de
manera automática y en un punto en que
ya no apreciamos ni los objetos ni las
actividades
y eso es lo que queremos evitar a todo
costo porque como dice aquí una vida si
es como si no hubiera existido y ese no
es el tipo de vida que queremos entonces
cuál es el antídoto para eso pues según
shklovski es el arte verdad y aquí
tenemos la segunda cita que dice el arte
existe para recobrar la sensación de
vivir la vida existe para que uno pueda
sentir cosas para sentirlo pedrosa que
es una piedra la técnica del arte es
eliminar la familiaridad de los objetos
hacer sus formas más complejas y su
percepción más larga y difícil el arte
nos facilita ver lo artístico en un
objeto el objeto en sí no es importante
ok es un poco complicado pero lo
importante es que si está hablando del
arte como un antídoto para una vida
inconsciente pero cuando hablas sobre el
arte no nos dice mejor en sus técnicas
de dibujo ni aprendan a esculpir bien ya
ni siquiera nos hicieran cosas bonitas
tampoco nos habla de la creatividad sino
que la frase importante aquí creo que es
donde nos dice eliminar la familia
eso se supone que es la verdadera
función del arte bueno vamos a ver un
par de ejemplos para que eso quede un
poco más claro
bueno aja qué significa eliminar la
familiaridad pues eliminar la
familiaridad significa simplemente sacar
de contexto y lo van a ver en las
siguientes imágenes que les voy a
mostrar
el mismo año que se escribió este ensayo
un artista francés llamado marcel
duchamp
hizo una obra de arte llamada fuente
esta obra fue muy revolucionaria en la
historia del arte y no sé tal vez
algunos de ustedes ya lo han visto se ve
así
como pueden ver se trata de un urinario
este y el urinario es un objeto de la
vida diaria de muchas personas y además
de esto no sólo un objeto ordinario sino
que el artista ni siquiera lo hizo con
sus propias manos él solo fue a una
tienda y lo compró o incluso creo que la
historia oficial es que alguien se lo
regaló y lo firmó y lo puso en un museo
y dijo esta es mi obra verdad
a muchos eso les podría soñar extraño
pero según la cita que leímos
anteriormente eso cumple al cien por
ciento con las características que se
necesitan para ser considerado una obra
de arte porque está sacando a este
objeto de su contexto usual y no los
está mostrando bajo una nueva luz me
imagino que cuando un hombre va al baño
y ve uno de éstos no se fija en esa
forma como triangular que tiene o en
esos bollitos que tiene ahí también sino
que lo ve como algo que sirve para
orinar o sea ve en él un uso y no un
objeto entonces porque hablamos de todo
eso que tiene que ver todo eso con con
honduras y la estética cultural pues les
voy a contar que yo era de esas personas
que decía que en la ceiba no había nada
que me parecía aburrido que no
no disfrutaba nada sentía que no había
nada que ver tal vez iba a la playa los
fines de semana la pasaba bien pero pero
cuando empecé a aprender sobre estos
conceptos y sobre esas obras de arte me
di cuenta que lo que me pasaba era que
había caído en la trampa de vivir una
vida inconsciente entonces decidí
aplicar estos conceptos a mi vida diaria
y lo que hice fue que decidí que todos
los días iba a encontrar algo de mi día
y le iba a tomar una foto y le iba a
subir a una página en instagram y si el
propósito era sacar a algo que veía
todos los días de su contexto para que
las personas en vez de verlos afuera en
la calle lo estuvieran viendo en las
pantallas de sus celulares
estas son algunas de las imágenes que
resultaron como podrán ver hay una gran
variedad de colores y si la recibimos en
una ciudad super colorida pero esos
colores y esos objetos estas escenas de
la vida diaria nos pasan desapercibidas
yo creo que es muy importante que cuando
las personas piensen en honduras piensan
en imágenes así también porque si sólo
nos sentimos orgullosas
de nuestras joyitas de nuestras de
nuestros tesoros de nuestra naturaleza
de estas imágenes extraordinarias solo
nos estamos sintiendo orgullosos de
parte de honduras pues yo siempre que a
un proyecto trato de reflexionar en como
como mi trabajo está aportando a que el
país mejore y quiero que éste sea mi
aporte de verdad a hacer una estética
cultural un poco más completa y creo
fielmente que si logramos hacer eso si
logramos popularizar esas imágenes vamos
a estar dando pasos tal vez un poco
inusuales pero creo que son
verdaderamente importantes hacia un país
mejor gracias
[Aplausos]